écoutez j'aurais juste excusé Catherine
de roche qui viennent nous rejoindre
dans les dans les mines qui vient
qui viennent pendant ça c'est le matin
bon
mes chers collègues donc nous entendons
ce matin et je les salue Monsieur
François Toujas président des
investissements français du sang à mes
côtés j'indique d'ailleurs que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo qui sera retransmis en direct sur
le site du Sénat et qui est disponible à
la demande monsieur je vous Président je
vous ai enfin la commission vous a
sollicité à la suite du dépôt de la
discussion de nombreux amendements
relatifs à l'Établissement français du
sang au projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale puis au projet de
loi de finance on a vu que c'était un
sujet de préoccupation de l'ensemble des
sénateurs les différents amendements
témoignés de l'inquiétude de nos
collègues sur le modèle français du soin
de leurs interrogations sur l'évolution
de l'établissement qui stressait
notamment par des demandes de rapport
nous avons dans un premier temps pensé à
demander une enquête à la Cour des
comptes comme le code des juridictions
financières nous le permet mais la Cour
a publié en 2019 une insertion au
rapport public annuel intitulée la
filière du sang en France un modèle
économique fragilisé une exigence de
transformation cette insertion de reste
inconstat sévère et préconise des
transformations profondes tout en
relevant les fragilités du modèle donc
nous avons souhaité que nous puissions
vous entendre ce matin afin que nos
collègues puissent trouver des réponses
alors question posée au cours de ces
automnes budgétaires et notamment
réaction en rapport qui avait été en
tout cas déposé voilà donc monsieur le
Président merci de votre présence et je
vous donne tout de suite la parole
merci beaucoup
mesdames sénatrices et Messieurs les
sénateur merci à la Commission pour
cette audition lors ma dernière audition
date du 28 juillet 2020 dans le cadre de
renouvellement de mes fonctions au
conseil d'administration d'établissement
français du sang
et ainsi que vous le notiez depuis cette
audition le modèle économique de
l'Établissement Français du sens c'est
fortement dégradé
on peut peut-être dire d'ailleurs que
l'établissement français du sang est
aujourd'hui sûrement un moment important
de son histoire si ce n'est un tournant
je voudrais rappeler devant vous que
l'établissement français du sang depuis
sa création puisqu'il a 23 ans à engager
des réformes structurelles a su se
transformer a su se moderniser
mais c'est vrai qu'il traverse
aujourd'hui une crise économique et
sociale sans précédent et importantes
je pense donc que la poursuite des
réformes de l'établissement est
essentiel pour pérenniser le modèle
éthique mais ne pourra pas se faire sans
investissement humain et financier
supplémentaire si
vous me permettez de façon très
synthétique je dirais que
l'établissement est confronté à 7 enjeux
majeurs
le premier enjeu c'est bien évidemment
de retrouver des capacités
opérationnelles satisfaisantes
adaptée aux nouveaux contextes et qui
permettent de déployer une offre de
collecte agile afin de garantir la
continuité du service qui est le nôtre à
la fois la collecte mais également la
délivrance de police sanguins dans les
hôpitaux
ceci nécessite l'amélioration de
l'attractivité des emplois offerts par
l'établissement qui sera un élément clé
de
ses capacités opérationnelles retrouvées
la définition plus importante de
parcours professionnel et puis des
enjeux autour de la qualité de vie au
travail je puisque je suis devant
le dessinateurs des sénatrices je dois
vous dire que ce matin puisque je
regarde les stocks tous les matins ce
matin nos stocks étaient à 80
300 poches de sang ce qui est
dangereux puisque
il est préférable pour la qualité du
service sur l'ensemble du territoire de
la République d'être aux alentours de 90
000 à 100000 poches et les événements
climatiques qui sont les nôtres enfin
que nous subissons ne vont pas changer
les choses concernant le les capacités
opérationnelles je voudrais aussi dire
que malgré ce qu'on peut penser
nous continuons comme d'ailleurs
d'autres structures de la Santé a subir
les effets de la crise covid qui
continue à faire des avoir des effets
importants et sur la mobilisation des
donneurs et sur notamment le niveau
d'absentéisme
le deuxième enjeu majeur auquel
l'établissement est confronté c'est bien
évidemment de participer au renforcement
de la filière française du
fractionnement par une augmentation
sensible des volumes de plasma collecté
pour cela
la revalorisation des prix de cession du
plasma qui est cédé au LFB et qui
interviendra au 1er janvier est une
bonne nouvelle puisqu'on a une
augmentation qui sera de 10% mais elle
doit se poursuivre et j'ai toujours dit
qu'à fin que nous puissions avoir une
filière plasma avec un élément celui qui
représente l'établissement français du
sang de collecte ou d'appareils de
collecte fort nous devons nous
rapprocher des coups mondiaux je vous
rappelle simplement que le litre que de
plasma collecté Cedeo LFB est en France
à 120 euros la moyenne européenne est en
170 et la moyenne aux États-Unis
d'environ 200 dollars on est donc encore
dans un retard important
troisième enjeu c'est de répondre
toujours mieux aux besoins de patients
dont on dit qu'ils sont dotés de
phénotypes d'intérêt ou de ce qu'on
appelle un son rare vous savez que la
répartition des groupes sanguins dans le
monde est différente en fonction des
origines des populations et beaucoup de
nos compatriotes dans sa stralité
africaine présente des caractéristiques
sanguines
différentes et donc il est très
important pour le dire un peu rapidement
que la population des donneurs
représente
ressemble à la population des malades et
ceux d'autant plus que certains de nos
compatriotes
dans cette réalité africaine souffre
plus particulièrement que d'autres de
maladies du sang qui ne sont soignées
que par des transfusions je parle je
pense notamment à la drépanocytose et
donc l'auto-suffisance quantitative
avoir assez de produits sanguins doit se
doubler d'une exigence d'auto suffisance
qualitative qui est un enjeu de santé
publique prioritaire qui est aussi
d'ailleurs un enjeu social et bien
évidemment un enjeu éthique majeur
le quatrième en jeu auquel nous sommes
confrontés que nous devons relever et
qui me paraît là aussi très important si
bien évidemment de participer au
développement
des thérapies d'avenir et notamment par
la mise en place ou la mise au point de
bio-thérapie avec une offre de
bioproduction qui permet au nom de la
souveraineté sanitaire de faire en sorte
que nous puissions nous aussi dans le
secteur de l'immunologie et de la
médecine régénératrice préparée
participer à la préparation des
médicaments de demain
vous l'avez dit dans votre introduction
il est aussi essayé de 5e enjeu
nécessaire de poursuivre la
transformation de l'Établissement
français du sang c'est un établissement
public c'est un établissement public qui
vit avec des financements publics il est
donc absolument nécessaire qu'il
continue à montrer plus d'efficience
mais aussi à accompagner des éléments
très importants que sont notamment sa
transformation numérique
deux derniers enjeux qui me paraissent
essentiels et qu'on oublie peut-être
évidemment je m'adresse à des
représentants de la nation nous pensons
que l'établissement doit aussi renforcer
la démocratie sanitaire renforcer la
démocratie sanitaire et participer à
l'année démocratie sanitaire ça veut
dire que dans les instances du
gouvernance de l'EFS sont déjà
représentés des représentants des
donneurs et des représentants des
patients il est important que nous
puissions dans nos réflexions
associées peut-être plus c'est
représentants ce que vous nous avons
d'ailleurs fait lors de la crise covid
et puis essaie
vous parliez du modèle éthique français
moi je pense que ce modèle
non seulement il faut les défendre mais
je pense qu'il faut le promouvoir parce
qu'il a montré son efficacité il a
montré son efficacité et je suis heureux
quand
certains de mes collègues étrangers me
demandent de venir expliquer comment ça
marche de voir à quel point
ce modèle est vu comme un modèle
important ce modèle est vu comme un
modèle efficace et plus que cela ce
modèle il faut se le rappeler
23 ans après est né d'une crise de santé
publique majeure qui était celle du sans
contaminé ce modèle je pense qu'il faut
le promouvoir et la promotion de ce
modèle c'est notamment parce que ce
modèle appartient à la nation
d'encourager et de favoriser
l'engagement citoyen j'étais notamment
très frappé lors de la crise des
attentats de voir à quel point dès le
lendemain beaucoup de jeunes
d'honneur venaient pour montrer leur
solidarité avec nos concitoyens qui
avaient été touchés
pendant ces attentats
alors j'aurais devant vous un langage de
vérité j'ai pas trop le sens de la
nuance j'en suis désolé
je l'ai eu lors du dernier conseil
d'administration qui est une en octobre
où il a difficulté oui la situation de
l'établissement est difficile
les difficultés persistent et nous
rencontrons de graves difficultés
qui réinterroge la totalité de nos
activités
première élément comment faire en sorte
que nous puissions garantir la
continuité d'activité puisque cette
continuité d'activité je le rappelle est
un élément essentiel de la sécurité
sanitaire puisque tous les jours ce sont
10000 produits sanguins qui doivent être
collectés et distribués aux malades
deuxième chose dès lors que la filière
de plasma pour fractionnement les
activités de de bioproduction qui sont
aujourd'hui déficitaires
si elle ne trouve pas de financement
vont-elles pas dire de choix que nous
pourrions faire ce qui aurait comme
conséquence bien évidemment de
réinterroger notre capacité à développer
cette reproduction et aussi à améliorer
notre collègue pour le placement pour
fonctionner
je voudrais
dire aussi que dès lors que
l'établissement se trouverait des
équilibré c'est toute une partie de la
souveraineté sanitaire du pays qui
serait questionné et donc il est
important de dire que avec les tutelles
nous recherchons les solutions
permettant de garantir en termes de
sécurité en termes de sécurité sanitaire
et donc de sécurité publique
un établissement bien évidemment agile
mais aussi assis correctement ou planter
correctement sur ces deux jambes je
voudrais d'ailleurs profiter de cette
audition pour remercier devant vous
l'ensemble des collaborateurs et des
collaboratrices de l'établissement
le contexte social et économique vous le
savez puisque vous avez été destinataire
je pense de de beaucoup de remontées y
compris sur le terrain a été difficile
nous sommes
à peine sortis
d'un conflit
social important qu'on puisse social
alors que la pandémie était encore là
vraiment les collaborateurs et
collaboratrices de l'établissement en
témoigné pendant cette période d'un
engagement continu
et porte haut et fièrement les valeurs
de services publics qui sont les nôtres
je voudrais aussi
dire devant vous que la situation de
l'établissement
avec une présence tous les jours sur les
territoires est aussi le fait d'une
relation très forte que nous avons avec
les associations de donneurs avec la
Fédération française pour le don du sang
bénévole et puis avec les bénévoles qui
nous aident sans eux rien ne serait
possible et puis dire aussi à quel point
les exigences
normal
des associations de patients étonnément
fondamental dans la façon dont nous
voyons nos évolutions
il est important également de souligner
et c'est des éléments dont on a pu
mesurer l'importance notamment pendant
la crise covid à quel point la relation
avec les collectivités locales étaient
fortes à quel point une bonne relation
avec notamment les collègues les mairies
pour des choses aussi simples mais
essentielles que la mise à disposition
de salle était essentiel si on voulait
continuer à travailler sur le terrain
puisque après tout l'établissement
français du sang c'est vraiment un
service public qui est baigné dans dans
les territoires
je le redis la situation de
l'établissement est difficile mais je le
redis aussi c'est un établissement qui
est essentiel et indispensable au
système de santé
il est évident que les difficultés qu'il
traverse il n'est pas les seuls à le
traverser on voit bien quand même que le
service le secteur de la santé à
traverser des difficultés difficiles et
n'en est pas sorti depuis la crise je
voudrais simplement redire aux heures et
aux autres aux unes et aux autres qu'on
ne manquait peut-être de beaucoup de
choses pendant ces crises dit-on
dans les dernières semaines
cette baisse a un impact bien évidemment
très défavorable sur le chiffre
d'affaires de l'établissement
alors que par ailleurs c'est grâce à la
session de police sanguins que
l'établissement financé des activités
par définition déficitaires comme
peuvent l'être les bio-productions la
recherche etc etc
l'activité de cession de plasma pour le
fractionnement et structurellement
déficitaire et donc il serait nécessaire
si l'on veut continuer à améliorer y
compris dans une relation tout à fait
forte avec le LFB les capacités de
collecte du LFB alors que l'usine
d'Arras va ouvrir mais il faudra que
nous puissions continuer à organiser une
revalorisation des
niveaux de cession auxquels sont cédés
pardon le les placements à Wall SV et
puis
trois points évidemment
participent à ces difficultés le premier
c'est bien évidemment les enjeux autour
du recrutement et de l'attractivité
puisque nous n'avons pas pu bénéficier
de la totalité
des revalorisations liées au Ségur de la
santé mais qu'une partie ce qui est
d'ailleurs provoqué le conflit que nous
avons réussi les gens remercient
le ministre à pouvoir avoir récemment
une augmentation de 3,5% des salaires
conform il s'était passé dans les
fonctions dans les fonctions publiques
et
dans la sécurité sociale mais par
ailleurs nous avons besoin de ce qui
était appelé à l'hôpital de Ségur de
c'est à dire que nous avons besoin de
financement pour réorganiser
restructurer nos classifications
donc ça c'est un point important avec
aujourd'hui on le voit bien des
difficultés non seulement de recrutement
mais de fidélisation du personnel et de
grandes difficultés et ce d'autant plus
que tu es une grande partie des réformes
que nous avons fait notamment sur la
collecte était basé sur la
revalorisation du rôle des infirmières
et des infirmiers notamment dans la
téléassistance médicale ou dans
l'entretien prédom qui peut vous être
qui peut dorénavant être fait par des
infirmières infirmiers alors que ce
l'était ça n'était pas possible avant
il faut aussi noter que l'établissement
s'ouvre d'une baisse de la productivité
alors pourquoi une baisse de la
productivité parce que vous comprendrez
bien que quand
pour dire quand une équipe part en
collecte mais il faut qu'il y ait toute
l'équipe complète et si pour des raisons
de maladies notamment une
infime une infirmière pardon manque bien
c'est toute la collecte qui ne se fait
pas on a mesuré que du 1er janvier à la
fin du mois d'octobre pas mon novembre
c'était plus de 1600 collectes qui
avaient été qui avaient été supprimés si
on prend comme hypothèse que c'est 1600
collectes c'est environ 80 dons de sang
160 1160 000 dons de sang
produit sanguin qui n'ont pas pu être
collectés et donc on a bien un sujet
important et puis
me doute bien que vous connaissez ce
sujet
nous sommes aussi extrêmement inquiets
de l'inflation terrible
qui bien évidemment va produire des
effets négatifs sur nos comptes puisque
sur environ 350 millions d'achats que
représentent l'établissement français
par an on compte en fonction de la
direction le budget que l'inflation nous
coûtera cette année 30 millions et donc
si je devais
synthétiser les problèmes
économiques budgétaires je veux dire de
l'établissement s'il y avait excusez-moi
d'être un tout petit peu synthétique
trois chiffres à retenir on a des
revalorisations salariale à venir qui
pourrait aller jusqu'à 30 millions on a
une baisse d'activité qui nous coûte
environ 30 millions par rapport à ce qui
se passait les années précédentes et
puis on a je le disais un choc
inflationniste qui sera au moins de 30
millions si on part du postulat une
bonne gestion c'est d'avoir un modèle
économique équilibré mais on fait 0 - 90
ça fait 80 ça fait - 90 et donc un que
nous avons aujourd'hui nous travaillons
avec l'ensemble des tutelles c'est de
voir comment nous pouvons présenter un
budget qui permette cette cette
continuation d'activité je suis
évidemment tout à fait optimiste même si
les choses sont des fois difficiles il
est bien évidemment qu'il y aura
sûrement des économies à trouver et je
suis sûr d'ailleurs que
les ministères représentants des
finances trouveront des choses à nous
dire là-dessus mais je reste persuadé
par ailleurs que comme pour le reste de
la santé on ne pourra pas
traverser ces enjeux de modèles
économiques sans ressources
supplémentaires
en conclusion dans ce contexte afin
d'assurer sa mission de service public
je le redis l'établissement c'est un bel
établissement que l'établissement
français du sang
moi je suis très fier de
présider je redis qu'il a une place
essentielle y compris d'ailleurs en
termes de
d'excellence de ce que peut être
l'éthique française avec de l'efficacité
et le refus de la marchandisation du
corps humain jamais nous n'avons manqué
de produits sanguins mais je le dis nous
devons améliorer notre activité les
enjeux de revalorisation les enjeux de
classification les enjeux de
conciliation entre la vie privée et la
vie professionnelle doivent trouver des
réponses et puis malgré ça à des
sénatrices et des sénateurs je rappelle
aussi que l'établissement la vraie vie
de l'établissement je suis un peu
critiqué quand je dis ça mais c'est pas
très grave la vraie vie l'établissement
elle est dans les territoires parce que
c'est dans les territoires que se font
les collègues c'est dans les territoires
que ce sont les mobilisations des uns et
des autres et je pense qu'il est donc
indispensable
de nous aider pour que nous continuions
à pouvoir nous projeter dans l'avenir je
vous remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le Président pour ces
explications on a donc cinq demandes de
prise de parole
donc je vais commencer par corinabert
Corinne
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur pour votre franchise
et l'éclairage que vous nous apporter ce
matin alors vous avez terminé vos propos
par en parlant des collectivités des
territoires alors peut-être que ma
première question pourrait être nous
faire un rapide bilan
de l'évolution des points de collecte
sur le territoire est-ce que vous avez
été obligé de renoncer non pas par les
collectivités qui ne pouvaient plus vous
mettre de service sociaux parce que vous
n'aviez pas d'équipe complète est-ce que
vous avez été obligé de renoncer à
beaucoup de points de collecte
sur l'aspect financier
et j'ai envie de la première question
c'est au-delà du fait que vous êtes
persuadé si j'ai bien compris et c'est
la raison de votre optimiste
en clair on pourra pas laisser tomber
établissement français les pouvoirs
publics pourront pas laisser tomber
l'Établissement français du sang et je
l'espère et nous pouvons être fiers de
notre modèle éthique et que vous avez
rappelé avec cette efficacité cette
non-mère marchandisation pour autant
vous avez rappelé les dernières
revalorisations des tarifs et les écarts
de prix par rapport à l'Europe et par
rapport aux États-Unis par exemple
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
l'évolution des subventions publiques
notamment la contribution de l'Assurance
Maladie décidé en compensation justement
de l'évolution du régime fiscal sur les
produits sanguins et les relations
financières de l'Établissement français
du sang et les entre l'établissement
franciscain et les hôpitaux en nous
rappelant le niveau de leurs dettes à
l'égard de l'Établissement français du
sang
pouvez-vous également nous rappeler où
on est la révision des textes européens
relatifs à la filière 100 et la position
que défend les différents États membres
le brexit a-t-il modifié les rapports de
force sur ces questions en Europe il
faut qu'il s'inquiéter dans les grandes
lignes ou dans le détail de la
négociation en cours pour le modèle de
Don éthique à la française parce que là
il y a un vrai sujet sérieux ça ça
revient sur les propos que je tenais
tout à l'heure et que vous avez tenu
un mot sur sur les 100 rares qui sont
plus nombreux dans les populations
d'origine africaine et karabée
caribn comment l'Établissement Français
du centre travaillent-ils encourager le
don dans les territoires d'outre-mer
qui est parfois rapporté à la population
moitié moindre qu'en métropole comment
vous arrivez à faire la promotion du
temps du sang et de quel type de soutien
de quelle collaboration auriez-vous
besoin pour augmenter l'impact de votre
communication à cette fin et enfin et ça
va rejoindre les questions de recherche
l'établissement français travaille
depuis plusieurs mois au développement
de traitement à base de carte et sel à
Besançon travaillez-vous à d'autres
formes d'immunothérapie et
l'Établissement français du sang peut-il
soutenir de tels chantiers en l'état
actuel de son modèle de financement vous
avez un peu donné la réponse voilà donc
il y a pas plus de choses à préciser
je vous en ferai grâce et je
comprendrais je vous remercie
mais supposons que je propose c'est déjà
de répondre à cette première serait de
questions dans notre rapporteur de la
Manche maladie avant d'ouvrir aux autres
sénateurs
bien merci Madame les sénatrice pour
pour ces questions alors le bilan sur
les pointes collègues de choses à la
fois les conséquences de la crise
épidémique sur le niveau d'absentéisme
pour être tout à fait clair on est
aujourd'hui à des taux d'absentéisme qui
ne sont pas redescendus et qui restent à
deux à trois points au-dessus de ce
qu'ils étaient avant la crise donc en
2019 qui est pour nous l'année de
référence et donc ça c'est un sujet la
deuxième chose sur lequel
je dois je dois intervenir effectivement
nous avons engagé
par des soucis déficien des enjeux
autour de la réorganisation de la
collecte qui s'est traduit par le fait
que alors qu'on avait environ environ un
peu moins mais je vais dire environ 40
000 collectes mobiles on est plus
aujourd'hui qu'à 29000 collectes mobiles
et donc on a concentré des choses qui
d'ailleurs comme conséquent de devoir
accompagner sur le territoire c'est
enjeux parce que
comment vous dire ça une association
d'honneur de sang elle vit parce qu'il y
a une collecte il y a plus de collecte
il y a plus d'association et donc ce
qu'on essaie de faire c'est de voir
comment on peut s'organiser sur les
territoires ruraux voilà j'en connais
certains puisque je suis issu de Gironde
et pas de Bordeaux mais tu vois et donc
un des des
associations qui ont fait des actions
cantonales par exemple et qui permettent
de qu'on maîtrise ces éléments donc ça
c'est un point important concernant les
finances de
l'évolution du financement vous savez
que euh
un des points importants de ce qu'on
appelait le choc fiscal en 2016 17 18 je
ne me rappelle plus exactement et que
nous avons dû nous mettre en conformité
avec le droit européen puisque
lors de la création de l'Établissement
français du sang le régime de TVA qui
était appliqué il a été découvert
quelques années après de mon point de
vue un peu trop tard quand même enfin
bon c'est la vie il a été découvert que
c'était pas conforme au droit donc on
nous a dit ben écoutez ce régime qui
peut représenter un avantage fiscal de
l'établissement pour l'établissement de
80 millions d'euros vous n'avez plus
donc il a fallu travailler de deux
manières l'État a pris des engagements
très forts nous permettant de faire en
sorte que par des avantages fiscaux on
puisse retrouver 40 millions elle nous a
demandé de faire 40 millions d'euros
d'économistes sur sa 40 millions d'euros
d'économie la il a été décidé pour nous
aider que
la subit une subvention de l'Assurance
Maladie cette subventions de l'assurance
maladie est une subvention de 40
millions d'euros dégressives tous les
ans 40 30 20 10 10
et voilà bien donc ça c'est la première
chose néanmoins au vu des enjeux et des
difficultés ce que je peux vous dire de
façon très claire sur le budget 2022 par
rapport au budget 2021
par le budget 2022 par rapport au budget
de maths 21 oui alors que nous étions au
total des subventions à des subventions
aux alentours de 30 de 33,5 millions
d'euros les subventions en 2012 étaient
2021,21 millions de vins pardon 2022
excusez moi de 21 millions d'euros je
rappelle quand même que le chiffre
d'affaires de l'Établissement français
du sang
c'est un milliard d'euros
d'accord que sur ce milliard d'euros il
y a 53
54% qui sont bien évidemment alors des
charges salariales ce qu'il faut faire
les gens et puis sur le reste c'est
plutôt des achats des machines puisqu'on
a environ 350 millions d'euros d'achat
par an
première chose donc c'est un gros et par
ailleurs c'est des milles salariés donc
alors j'ai toujours que ce n'est pas une
agence que c'est un établissement mais
c'est un gros établissement de santé ça
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
comment quel est le modèle de
financement
80% du financement de l'établissement
est fait sur la session de produits
sanguins aux hôpitaux
par un arrêté qui fixe le niveau de prix
donc il n'y a pas pour le dire autrement
il n'y a pas de j'entends souvent des
des choses que je dois être un peu il y
a pas de marché du sang puisque c'est un
monopole et ce monopole se traduit par
le fait un qu'il n'y a pas de
concurrence à l'Établissement français
du sang ce que je trouve heureux et que
par ailleurs il n'y a pas de marché
puisque on a un prix qui est fixé
administrativement ce prix est fixé
administrativement mais vous voyez où
est le sujet c'est que le prix est un
prix avec un produit de avec des
produits de session qui représente pour
les hôpitaux une charge et donc et donc
le le financement de l'établissement il
apparaît finalement assez peu dans les
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale puisqu'il est plutôt dans lambda
hospitalier
et que le vrai sujet c'est bien
évidemment
comment en arbitre et je peux le
comprendre comment en arbitre sur sur
ces sujets dans une situation dans
laquelle on voit bien l'hôpital a des
difficultés mais où je rappelle que
l'établissement ben doit aussi
travailler donc voilà pour cet élément
deuxième élément contre ce que vous
disiez pour la question que vous posez
nous avons effectivement une relation
avec le LFB qui est une relation dans
laquelle la totalité
plasma pour fractionnement que nous
collectons et livrer au LFB donc on
collecte deux types de produits on
collecte des produits sanguin habile
globules rouges plaquettes plasma
thérapeutique c'est produit sanguins la
bile vont dans les services hospitaliers
pour prendre en charge des malades et on
produit aussi un autre produit sanguin
qu'on appelle du plasma pour
fractionnement ce plasma pour
fonctionnement sert de matières
premières à la fabrication de
médicaments un peu particulier qu'on
appelle des médicaments dérivés du
plasma ces médicaments dérivés du plasma
sont fabriqués par des
firmes pharmaceutiques
et nous nous cédons ce plasma à un prix
administratif aussi aux fractionnaire
français qui est le laboratoire français
des biotechnologies le LFB
ça se passe là aussi sans qu'il y a un
marché puis c'est un prix et ce prix est
un prix administratif non je rappelais
qu'il était très en deçà du cours
mondial voilà
concernant les relations entre le FS et
les hôpitaux
d'abord elles sont très très bonnes
parce que
l'essentiel c'est quand même la prise en
charge des malades et que dans les
équipes cliniques on va nous demander
beaucoup on demande beaucoup à nos
équipes d'ih délivrance de faire du
Conseil transfusionnel et donc ça c'est
important la deuxième chose c'est que
c'est ces équipes sont souvent au sein
de l'hôpital et puis enfin il y a une
relation qui est une relation financière
et oui il y a certains hôpitaux qui nous
doivent de l'argent
la dette hospitalière
la dette hospitalière sans donner le nom
des hôpitaux mais la dette hospitalière
est d'environ 13 millions d'euros
13 millions d'euros
alors après vous dire une question donc
sur sur la directive européenne
indirective européenne alors de ne
devrait pas être une directive mais sur
un règlement
et je suis très heureux de pouvoir dire
qu'on a beaucoup travaillé sur ces
sujets évidemment
le ministère a pris des positions parce
que c'est pas le FS à prendre une
position mais deux ou trois éléments que
je trouve extrêmement rassurant
sur la directive européenne qui sera
donc un règlement un c'est de rappeler
la non marchandisation du corps humain
et ça je pense que c'est très important
de le rappeler et de favoriser le don
éthique et je trouve que là aussi
le modèle français tel qu'il est chez
nous
fort et très très vomir
et très ancré
je dis toujours qu'il faut pas seulement
le défendre de façon un peu ringarde
mais qu'il faut le promouvoir parce que
je pense que c'est ce type de modèle qui
peut répondre et on l'a vu je recevais
une délégation libanaise
on a avec les Libanais une relation très
forte où on les aide à avoir à faire en
sorte que ce modèle qui est un modèle
éthique permet de dire que
quand vous dire ça quand un malade est
malade c'est pas lui aller chercher du
sang mais c'est à la collectivité
alfornir cette
idiotie que je viens de donner c'est pas
une évidence partout en tout cas ça
allait en France il faut qu'on travaille
sur ce sujet voilà donc sur ce point là
sur le sur le brexit alors
paradoxalement
les transfuseurs ont créé une
association européenne l'étranger leur
public qui s'appelait le Béa
blood alliance et les les
créateurs c'était les Néerlandais les
finlandais les Français et les Anglais
et donc pour nous le brexit
ça veut dire que nos collègues anglais
dont on était très proches
on les voit moins et ça c'est pas
forcément quelque chose de quelque chose
de bien et puis vous avez aussi parlé
d'un sujet qui est extrêmement important
qui est celui descendra on dit toujours
que il y a pas beaucoup de groupes
sanguins c'est faux il y a 360 systèmes
de groupes sanguins 360 système de
groupe sanguins
et il est aussi démontré que la
répartition des groupes sanguins en
fonction des origines et très
différentes il y a par exemple beaucoup
plus de haut et notamment de opositif en
Afrique qu'il y en a dans en Europe
le brassage des populations les
les enjeux de nos compatriotes des DOM
mais aussi moi je dis souvent
d'outre-mer c'est au milieu de
l'Île-de-France aussi donc c'est partout
on peut pas fait que il est absolument
nécessaire que nous puissions je le dis
avoir une population de donneurs qui
ressemble aux populations de manade la
drépanocytose et la première maladie
biologique génétique n'importe quoi et
de la première maladie génétique qui
touche plus de 10000 personnes
un drépanocytaire aujourd'hui et
heureusement il commençait à y avoir des
des médicaments de thérapie innovantes
qui semblent marcher mais un
drépanocytaire a aujourd'hui grâce aux
systèmes de santé français à aujourd'hui
une espérance de vie
comparable à celle du non de
drépanocytaire la seule condition c'est
qu'il va le recevoir 300 400
transfusions
dans sa vie
et comme le corps humain est une machine
relative bien faite il faut bien
évidemment que le sang qu'il reçoit
corresponde
au sang qu'il a déjà parce qu'autrement
son corps va le refuser et on risque de
dans une impasse transfusionnel ça c'est
un premier point qui est un point
médical deuxième point qui est un point
éthique
ou culturel comment s'adresse-t-on à des
populations qui par définition sont
peut-être un peu plus éloignées du don
du sang traditionnel que la moyenne
alors ce qu'on a décidé c'est d'abord de
parler à ceux qui savent donc à des
assos voilà
avec des assauts des assos assez sympa
d'ailleurs de music urbaine et tout donc
moi ça accro à ma culture musicale et
puis on va aussi dans des
dans des mairies où il y a notamment une
journée des associations et on essaie de
voir s'il y a une association qui
antillaise qui comorienne auquel on dit
attention mais c'est bien venez donner
votre sang et puis on a aussi décidé que
le problème de descend rares devait
faire l'objet aussi de communication et
donc c'est la deuxième année que nous
faisons début
novembre une semaine de sensibilisation
au sang rare et ou des professeurs ont
expliqué dans des écoles et dans des
associations quel est l'enjeu de ces 100
rares voilà donc ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose que je dois dire
aussi et il faut le dire parce que
parce que l'établissement
français du sang c'est la République
donc c'est la solidarité
l'enjeu de la collecte
de ces sans rares que ce soit dans les
DOM ou que ce soit dans l'Hexagone est
essentiel parce que avec certains de ces
100 rares nous sommes amenés à prendre
en charge je me rappelle d'un cas d'une
petite fille qui était très malade à
Grenoble et qui avait un sens
extrêmement rare on a trouvé deux
donneurs un seul était disponible en
Martinique et donc on a bien des enjeux
de de nécessité de continuer à collecter
ou d'accroître la collecte dans ces
territoires je crois que la dernière
question pardon c'était peut-être un peu
trop non c'est la question c'était
bioproduction oui on fait de
l'immunothérapie on a aussi on est aussi
en train de travailler sur des enjeux
alors je suis passionne de pouvoir comme
ça en parler parce que c'est des enjeux
autour de autour de de quelques secrets
industriels mais en étant en train
notamment de travailler beaucoup sur de
la médecine régénérative ou comment à
partir d'une cellule souche
de cette cellule souche vous la
travaillez un peu et puis elle peut
devenir une reconstruction de muscles
cardiaque elle peut redevenir de la peau
etc etc et donc ce sont des enjeux qui
sont magnifiques sauf que c'est des
enjeux qui coûtent aujourd'hui 20
millions d'euros et que et que si on
n'est pas financé ça sera difficile de
continuer de continuer cette aventure
qui est fondamentale pour la médecine de
demain désolé d'avoir été un peu trop
long merci pour vos réponses on va
continuer donc les interventions
Laurence Cohen
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
pour pour vous explications qui sont
extrêmement précises et utiles je fais
partie comme beaucoup d'ailleurs de mes
collègues de celles et ceux qui sont
intervenus pour soutenir votre
établissement parce que effectivement
c'est un modèle vraiment à préserver et
je pense qu'on doit tous c'est tout en
être fier mais donc il faut il faut
essayer de faire en sorte qu'il perdure
et qu'il s'améliore donc beaucoup
d'interventions que ce soit courrier
auprès du ministère de la Santé question
écrite amendement mais malheureusement
sans succès le dernier amendement
proposé de mon groupe et de temps
d'augmenter au niveau du PLF de 200 je
crois que c'est plus 200000 euros ce qui
était bien modeste contenu finalement de
la dette de l'établissement parce que si
je ne me trompe pas il y avait une dette
de 58 millions en 2021
millions en 2022 donc ça fait 69
millions et si j'ai bien compris dont 13
millions de la dette hospitalière donc
là j'aimerais vous entendre sur en fait
le soutien des différents gouvernements
en réalité parce que à partir du moment
où le choix c'est un choix d'un
établissement public il y a besoin de
moyens financier moyen humain on le voit
dans les crises dans les communiqués que
vous avez pu faire et puis on a eu des
échos aussi des salariés il y a une
souffrance quand même au niveau du
travail parce qu'il y a un manque de
personnel il y a un manque de
reconnaissance aussi du métier exercé et
on l'a vu ça a été souligné les
personnels n'ont pas bénéficié
entièrement du Ségur donc pourquoi cette
différenciation avec ce personnel qui
est un personnel de santé
et qui donc ne bénéficient pas des
avantages qui ont pu être accordés même
si j'ai entendu que il y avait un effort
de fait puisque il y avait une ils
allaient obtenir une augmentation de
salaire mais on est bien loin de ce qui
serait nécessaire donc c'est c'est
difficile pour les conditions de travail
actuel pour maintenir l'établissement et
les ambitions mais c'est aussi difficile
pour l'attractivité du métier parce que
c'est ce que vous soulignez donc dans ce
contexte en général on l'a vu à la
commission des affaires sociales et un
manque d'attractivité des professions de
santé on va dire globalement mais pour
ce qui nous intéresse ce matin comment
quels sont finalement vos stratégies si
je puis dire pour essayer de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait plus de salariés au
niveau de l'établissement de santé que
vous ayez la possibilité de bien les
rémunérer donc ça c'est ma ma première
question ma deuxième ma deuxième
question c'est que vous avez souligné
les produits les réserves en produits
sanguins donc qui sont qui sont
insuffisantes pour partie on peut
l'expliquer au niveau de la crise de la
covid c'est d'ailleurs ce que vous avez
dit mais je pense quand même que c'est
c'est baisse en quelque sorte de réserve
ont peut-être été aussi antérieures
c'est-à-dire que est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
un fléchissement je vais dire au niveau
des des dons et du coup quels sont aussi
les politiques qui peuvent être menées
pour attirer les les les populations à
pouvoir donner et la troisième question
c'est que en fait il y a quelque chose
qui est
[Musique]
paradoxal je vais le dire comme ça c'est
à dire que en fait vous donc céder du
sang aux hôpitaux
le prix est fixé par décret donc c'est
administratif il n'y a pas de
marchandisation ça j'ai bien compris
mais en fait ça repose sur les hôpitaux
donc c'est un peu enfin un établissement
public du sang
qui en fait a besoin de l'argent
d'hôpitaux publics enfin vous voyez
c'est un peu c'est dingue quoi enfin je
sais pas comment le dire autrement mais
normalement ça devrait pas être ce
circuit là il devrait y avoir un autre
financement de de me semble-t-il de
votre établissement enfin voilà et là et
du coup et vous avez dit également que
par rapport au plasma
pour fractionnement etc donc c'était
utilisé j'ai bien compris pour les
médicaments certains médicaments et là
encore c'est au niveau administratif des
etc donc toujours vous vous êtes enfin
c'est bien enfin vous êtes bien dans la
mission non mais je veux dire dans la
mission qui vous incombe il y a pas il y
a pas de marchandisation il y a pas il y
a pas tout ça c'est ce que j'essaie de
dire maladroitement mais en même temps
ça va être utilisé et c'est très bien
par des labos
pour produire pour produire des
médicaments et donc eux à juste titre
après ils vont vendre ces médicaments
avec un un profit c'est normal quand
dans la société dans laquelle on est
qu'il y a aussi un profit qui soit fait
par un certain nombre de d'entreprises
mais les grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques ont des profits
faramineux donc là encore je trouve
qu'il y a un peu une anomalie ou une
injustice pour le dire avec diplomatie
merci Laurence cette fois Elisabeth
Doisneau on va prendre trois
intervenants merci monsieur le président
et bien écoutez je voudrais rajouter
comme mes collègues combien nous sommes
très sensibles à l'activité de
l'établissement français du sang que
nous étions même inquiets au moment du
PLFSS parce que nous avions les uns et
les autres reçus vos courriers
d'information et que nous avons été
nombreux à prendre la parole à ce sujet
moi j'avais trois points de vigilance
mais ils ont été rappelés par mes
collègues dont je vais pas être très
très longue en fait ce qui nous
inquiétait à ce moment-là c'était
qu'effectivement depuis 2019 et bien le
régime de taux de TVA sur les produits
sanguins labyl avait changé et que donc
du coup vous retrouviez avec des
financements moindres de ce côté-là mais
vous avez très bien expliqué les choses
le deuxième point de vigilance c'était
par rapport au personnel et là je crois
que que le Ségur une fois de plus a
frappé parce que
le fait qu'il ait été impliqué de
manière voilà un peu graduée a fait que
votre établissement comme d'autres se
sont trouvés avec une concurrence au
niveau du personnel et que c'était vous
avez fait ennuyeux pour un établissement
comme le vôtre qui a besoin de tourner à
plein régime donc est-ce que aujourd'hui
vous avez retrouvé la capacité d'attirer
je dirais les talents et les
professionnels de santé qui doivent être
à vos côtés pour réaliser l'ensemble du
travail qui est le vôtre et puis comment
finalement un peu réenchanter ces
métiers autour de l'activité du sens et
c'est la question que je voulais vous
poser et là le troisième point de
vigilance c'était sur les bénévoles
parce que les uns les autres nous sommes
invités dans des associations locales
moi je suis sur l'épée de la Loire je
sais que c'est une région qui est
comment traître comment dirais-je en
tout cas qui s'est mobilisé les
bénévoles pour l'activité très fortement
l'activité de collecte mais ils sont en
difficulté aujourd'hui moi les dernières
assemblées que j'ai pu faire ils nous
disent qu'ils ont moins de bénévoles
depuis les les comment les épidémies de
covid et que c'est difficile pour eux de
recruter quelque sorte moi je pense
qu'il y a quand même une action à faire
auprès des jeunes parce que il faudra
toujours s'intéresser aux nouvelles
générations qui qui pourront prendre une
nouvelle habitude par rapport aux dons
du sang et en tout cas je voudrais vous
remercier à travers mes propos parce que
je pense que sans vous sans
l'Établissement français du sang mais
aussi bien les professionnels et les
bénévoles on serait bien en difficulté
donc merci à l'ensemble du personnel et
des bénévoles
un homme nasarade
je suis désolé merci madame la
Présidente
moi je suis allée dans des points de
détails qui sont un peu moins financiers
on a
au niveau j'imagine du dépistage
d'hépatite on a actuellement
possibilité d'éradiquer les hépatites en
particulier hépatite C par des
traitements efficaces est-ce que vous
participez à ce dépistage est-ce que
vous orientez et
bon je sais que vous êtes en région
bordelaise moi aussi je suis sénatrice
de la Gironde et ça c'est la première
question voilà
deuxièmement
au point de vue
dérivé dérivés du plasma
que vous que vous confiez aux des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques quel est le
taux actuellement pour les hémophiles de
recours aux dérivés du plasma est-ce que
je pense que ça ça a bien baissé est-ce
que est-ce que c'est dérivés sont
finalement plus ou moins utilisé que que
qui a une vingtaine ou une trentaine
d'années par exemple est-ce qu'on est on
a toujours besoin de se dérivés ou
est-ce que les d'autres techniques
alternatives ont voilà j'essaie de parce
que les autres questions ont déjà été
posées
vous répondez maintenant
bonjour madame la Présidente
donc
concernant vos questions madame coller
le coin pendant le
poser une question qui est difficile
parce que demander qu'elle est quelle
est ma relation avec les tutelles vous
comprenez que je suis un devoir de
loyauté que je suis nommé par les
tutelles et et voilà et voilà donc on a
une relation qui est comment dire
exigeante et constructive voilà pour le
dire comme ça et puis vous dire aussi
que mon la façon dont je vois mon
travail c'est aussi de défendre des
intérêts de FS
et donc dans cette relation entre
guillemets exigeante et constructive
j'essaie de rappeler assez régulièrement
de ne pas oublier l'Établissement
français du sang et objectivement je
vois bien que
je ne vais pas dire que c'est simple
tout le temps mais que il y a une écoute
quand même très très forte sur ce que je
peux dire concernant des enjeux de santé
publique
parce que disons-le enfin c'est un peu
catastrophique de parler comme ça mais
imaginons ce que serait demain le
système de santé si on manquait de sang
enfin donc les gens sont évidemment
tout à fait responsables sur ce sujet
même si même si même si je trouve
qu'effectivement peut-être que le fait
d'avoir été entendu trop lentement sur
les enjeux autour du Ségur
a eu comme conséquence de produire un
conflit social difficile
qui a eu des conséquences évidemment
assez évidentes sur la relation qu'on
avait avec les partenaires sociaux même
si le fil de dialogue n'a jamais été
coupé et même si tout ça s'est passé
dans un moment qui était extrêmement dur
enfin je pense que vous nous l'avons
tous vécu qui était ce moment très très
difficile de la de la crise sanitaire et
donc je trouve que de ce point de vue là
on est allé peut-être un peu un peu
peut-être que les réponses ont été
partielles et je ne désespère pas
de je continue
mes demandes pour que les choses se
passent correctement ça c'est la
première chose sur sur les sur les
ressources humaines voyez bien qu'il y a
deux sujets et à la fois un sujet je
pense et je crois que la crise
épidémique a profondément
modifier des choses on a à la fois un
sujet d'attractivité salariale mais je
pense qu'on a aussi de vrais enjeux sur
lesquels je tous les employeurs et
notamment les employeurs sociaux doivent
rêver doivent réfléchir j'écoutais avec
attention ce que disait le nouveau
directeur général de l'AP-HP on a un
vrai sujet de qualité de vie au travail
on a un vrai sujet de faire en sorte que
la
compatibilité entre vie professionnelle
et vie privée se fasse correctement et
que les éléments de la fidélisation des
personnels face aussi par ça alors pas
au moins autant que par que par que par
le salaire ça c'est deuxième chose que
je tenais à dire troisième chose
concernant vos interrogations
on est dans des moments de réserve basse
la dernière année très belle a été 2019
on voit bien quand même que un des
éléments de la crise a bien été de
rendre beaucoup plus difficile à
mobilisation des donneurs je vous donne
un exemple nous avons nous avons un
million 600000 donneurs actifs c'est
quoi un donneur actif c'est un donneur
qui a donné au moins une fois par an sur
un million 600000 donneurs actifs il y a
10% de ces donneurs tous les ans qui
partent de nos fichiers soit parce
qu'ils ont trop vieux soit parce qu'ils
ont eu une maladie et donc on est obligé
de renouveler environ 10% ce
renouvellement de 10% a comme
conséquence qu'on va s'adresser ce qu'on
fait essentiellement aux jeunes
comment s'adresse-t-on aux jeunes
qui sont importants dans le dans le
notre population 30% des donneurs en
moins de 30 ans donc on peut pas dire
que les jeunes ne s'intéressent pas au
don du sang 30% des donneurs en moins de
30 ans c'est quand même assez beau comme
chiffre mais le sujet qu'on a c'est
qu'il faut un s'adresser à eux et de les
fidéliser comment fidélise-t-on des gens
quand pendant le covid les universités
sont fermées les écoles sont fermées
comment est-ce qu'on fidélise un moment
donné d'autres travailleurs alors que
30% de notre offre et quelques fois une
offre d'entreprise et que les et qu'on a
un recours au télétravail on voit bien
quand même que ces modes d'organisation
on profondément comment dire changer
notre façon d'appeler les donneurs et
donc on est obligé effectivement de
trouver d'autres manières parce qu'on
voit bien que la crise et les
modifications de de de la des conditions
de la vie quotidienne ont des enjeux
directs sur la moisson des donneurs
exemple
idiot peut-être mais réel
la crise qui a eu un moment donné sur
les raffineries les difficultés sur les
sens a eu des conséquences directes sur
le fait qu'on a mobilisé moins d'honneur
les problèmes météo vont avoir des
conséquences directes voilà et donc on a
bien envoyé des sujets qui sont enfin le
donneur c'est
un citoyen qui est là qui a besoin de
faire si ça enfin voilà donc c'est c'est
des vrais sujets c'est la raison pour
laquelle on travaille beaucoup sur de
nouveaux modes de communication et je
pense aussi c'est une question qui m'a
pas été posée par vous madame la
sénatrice mais par une autre personne je
pense que c'est où Madame et c'est le
même sujet on voit bien que la crise
épidémique a eu aussi des conséquences
tout à fait néfastes sur la capacité de
mobilisation des bénévoles donc je ne
voudrais pas moi je d'abord je salue les
bénévoles je veux pas dire trop de
bêtises mais les bénévoles à un moment
donné c'est plutôt des gens qui sont
un tout petit peu âgé
pendant la crise
on nous a dit attention vous ne pouvez
pas mobiliser des gens depuis 70 ans
parce qu'ils sont plus âgés donc est-ce
qu'on fait et comment on fait et on voit
bien que la mobilisation
a été plus difficile
pendant le même temps parce qu'il
fallait pour des raisons de santé
publique
continuer à collecter du son on a mis en
place les rendez-vous
et pourquoi on a mis en place les
rendez-vous pas parce que c'était mieux
pour nous même si une kiné ça nous
permet de mieux gérer mais parce que
c'était le seul moyen que nous avons
trouvé avec les directions générales de
la santé pour continuer à faire en sorte
que l'on puisse donner sans mettre en
cause la santé ni des donneurs ni des
collaborateurs et collaboratrices de
l'établissement parce qu'on pouvait
gérer plus facilement une file d'attente
et une des questions qui s'est posée
c'est bien nous association c'est quoi
notre rôle quand tu as des rendez-vous
et donc cette question là qui s'est
posée c'est un travail qu'on a engagé
avec avec les associations pour voir
comment on peut on peut travailler sur
ce sujet parmi les autres questions donc
sur le personnel j'ai répondu
tel établissement vous en parlez madame
Deano a eu un choc de TVA il y a eu un
choc de TVA c'est à dire que du jour au
lendemain nous a dit ben 40 millions
d'économies faut le faire dans ma
responsabilité a été de faire en sorte
qu'on puisse y arriver
et je voudrais le dire très directement
nous avons réussi à faire en sorte que
ce choc de TVA ce jour fiscal se change
je vais dire autrement les conséquences
financières du changement de régime
fiscal mais nous avons été jusqu'au bout
des choses et nous avons réussi à passer
à passer ce cap je rappelle qu'avant la
crise en 2019 nous livrions par exemple
au LFB 900 ml de poche de sang et que
nos comptes étaient équilibrées
comment réenchanter mais c'est un vrai
sujet et je moi je compte beaucoup sur
les enjeux autour de autour des autour
des jeunes parce que vraiment on voit
que sur la mobilisation des jeunes sur
ces sujets est important et je pense
même je pense même
que on a un vrai enjeu de mobilisation
des jeunes bénévoles auxquels on peut
peut-être pas demander je comprends
d'ailleurs de prendre des
responsabilités associatives parce
qu'ils ont autre chose à faire etc mais
on voit bien qu'il commence y avoir
plein de jeunes sur les collectes et ça
c'est plutôt
rassurant et puis l'autre point qui
était sur les enjeux autour de des
dépistage pour madame la sénatrice de
Gironde oui effectivement nous dépistons
notamment l'hépatite C et tout et quand
nous faisons alors pardon nous dépistons
sur toutes les poches de sang
toutes les poches de sang sont donc
dépistées
et donc dès qu'il y a un problème ou une
anomalie la personne est évidemment un
informer de en langage allez voir à
aller voir son médecin concernant alors
je suis pas
non
non parce que c'est pas notre c'est pas
notre mission
mais on met on dit allez voir un médecin
et puis alors l'autre question donc moi
je suis pas trop spécialiste de la prise
en charge des enjeux de l'hémophilie ce
que je peux dire en revanche et qui est
un sujet
auquel il faut faire très attention
les médicaments dérivés du plasma il y
en a plein d'un facteur de coagulation
blabla mais il y a un médicament qui est
très important qui sont les
immunoglobulines et les immunoglobulines
sont des médicaments dont on voit bien
qu'il y a une très forte consommation la
croissance mondiale des immunoglobulines
c'est plus dix à 12% par an en disant la
France a multiplié par deux sa
consommation d'immuno globulines c'est
par ailleurs des produits très riches
excusez-moi c'est pas d'ailleurs des
produits qui coûtent très cher excusez
moi qui sont donc aujourd'hui dans des
pays riches mais qui vont se généraliser
et donc le vrai sujet qu'on a
je voudrais juste encore je suis désolé
de saisir mais il faut savoir que
80% du plasma utilisé dans la
fabrication des médicaments dérivés du
plasma et collecter aux États-Unis
dans des conditions qui sont quand même
quelquefois très loin de l'éthique si je
peux me permettre on a donc bien une
vraie urgence notamment aux Françaises
et européenne à accroître notre capacité
de prélèvement vous voyez mal alors moi
je le dis aussi parce qu'il faut faire
attention à ces sujets certains il faut
être autosuffisant en médicament dérivés
du plasma non on n'est pas vrai je pense
que le concept de l'autosuffisance
sur ces médicaments n'est pas possible
puisqu'on est dans un dans un marché je
pense qu'en revanche on a un vrai sujet
de faire baisser notre dépendance et
d'accroître notre capacité de collecte
conformément d'ailleurs à ce qui s'est
fait avec la construction
par le lfv de l'usine d'Arras voilà
alors maintenant Daniel Chassin les
victoires jasmin merci madame la
Présidente donc merci Monsieur le
Directeur
de toutes les explications et je pense
que
remercier vous remercier et remercier
vos collaborateurs et je pense qu'aussi
nous pouvons être fiers de notre de
notre modèle donc si vous voulez bien
sûr le l'Établissement français du sang
est indispensable qu'on voulait dire au
service de santé comment on s'en
aperçoit tous les jours capital pour la
santé publique et pour l'avenir alors
vous avez répondu à beaucoup de
questions j'en aurais seulement une
puisqu'il y a pas de vous nous avez dit
pas de revalorisation tarifaire depuis
2015 ce qui est quand même très
important vous avez une baisse de
consommation des des hôpitaux
et aussi vous faites participer à aux
thérapies d'omnies on avait parlé des
immeubles globulines mais surtout des
cellules souches qui vont être peut-être
très importantes dans l'avenir et aussi
le plasma qui en fait n'est pas le prix
de vente est fixé aussi par par mais pas
votre autorité de tutelle donc tout ça
on vous demande en plus 40 milliards
d'économies plus l'inflation qui fait 30
milliards donc on comprend que vous
finances puissent être dégradés dans moi
c'est une seule question
on a besoin
de l'Établissement français du sang qui
est capital pour la santé pour l'avenir
et même si vous avez des relations
constructives combien actuellement
quelles sont les financements qui qui
sont nécessaires pour que
cet établissement puisse retrouver des
un fonctionnement normal et et le nombre
d'emplois et aussi bien sûr vous avez
été oublié du Ségur de la santé ce qui
est absolument inadmissible parce que
quand les gens font faire des collègues
ils vont rencontrer des gens qui peuvent
avoir bien sûr le covid et ça c'est
quand même tout à fait anormal que vous
soyez les oubliés du Ségur voilà merci
victoire
qui porte beaucoup au don du sang en
Guadeloupe l'association de morne-à-loup
alors si vous vous renseignez c'est une
association très active et qui joue un
rôle important sur un organe parce
qu'ils ont organisé il y a pas longtemps
et en tout cas avec la communauté
d'agglo donc c'est à communale
quelquefois et là avait à l'échelon dans
une organe et je trouvais que c'était
vraiment très pertinent mais je pense
que au niveau de la communication il y a
encore beaucoup à faire en Guadeloupe
alors je reviendrai également sur
une des questions que je vous avais
posée en fait je j'avais attiré votre
attention en tout cas lors de votre
dernière audition ici parce que vous
aviez envisagé un moment de centraliser
les examens les analyses biologiques des
collègues enfin les collectes et les
centraliser sur l'hexagone pour
peut-être maîtriser les coûts et vous
avez vu avec la pandémie que qu'on
serait vraiment dans une situation
catastrophique si vous aviez fait ce
choix là donc je vous remercie d'avoir
éviter de mettre en place ces
dispositions que vous envisagiez alors
par contre concernant la critiquation il
a amélioration continue de la qualité
j'ai quelques soucis
il y a eu un incendie à l'effet de
Guyane
cette incendie aurait pu être évité il y
a pas de détecteur de fumée alors que la
réglementation l'exige en plus on est
dans un établissement public quand même
l'alarme Emmanuelle et cette alarme
manuel
n'était pas opérationnel donc cette
incendie si on avait eu de nuit
peut-être qu'on aurait eu des victimes
donc il faut l'aurait vraiment qu'il y
ait
une démarche d'amélioration continue de
la qualité mais à tous les niveaux au
niveau de la sécurité également des
biens parce que vous parlez des
difficultés financières et budgétaires
que vous avez mais en tout cas dans tout
ce qui vous avez perdu lors de cet
incendie et bien ça aurait pu être
encore beaucoup plus parce que là c'est
parce que les gens ont envie de la fumée
c'était deux jours il y avait des
personnes présentes et là où on doit
aller parce que c'est une alarme
manuelle mais il faut aller là où y
aller sans dire que là la personne les
personnes qui étaient là ont pris des
risques donc j'assis votre attention sur
cela vous avez parlé de la baisse du
nombre de collecte mais assez Martin il
y a plus de collecte
il y a plus de collection il y a
quelques années
c'est vrai que il faut tenir compte de
rotation des avions c'est pas toujours
possible donc il faut peut-être une
unité quand les collectes se font sur
place mais je crois que c'est un
collègue je voudrais quand même pouvoir
parler
s'il vous plaît merci donc ces collègues
qui ne se font plus à se montrer sa vie
alors que là il reste de Guadeloupe
c'est ARS Guadeloupe c'est Martini et
bien les collectes pourtant le FS de
Guadeloupe c'est quoi donc il y a un
vrai problème à ce niveau là il faudrait
peut-être pour rentabiliser parce qu'il
y a quand même des personnes qui sont là
et qui bénéficient de ses collègues des
collègues faites à la fois en Guadeloupe
quelquefois Martinique et si dans
l'Hexagone donc là ce serait à refaire
pour la Guyane j'avais attiré votre
attention également on peut aujourd'hui
faire le diagnostic biologique des
Chagas et ce n'est pas normal qu'on ne
puisse pas
continuer parce que là ça s'est arrêté
depuis des années faire une évaluation
et là je vous en avais parlé ici même
faire une évaluation de la situation
pour voir si vous êtes en mesure de
reprendre les collectes en Guyane parce
que là ça pose problème et vous l'avez
également vu pendant la pandémie et la
Guyane est resté isolée beaucoup plus
longtemps que le reste des autres mères
donc alors que beaucoup de sang
arrive depuis l'hexagone pour la Guyane
mais aussi dans les rotations avec les
Antilles la Guadeloupe la Martinique il
y avait un souci parce qu'il y avait pas
non plus de de rotation les avions ne
pouvaient pas aller en Guyane pour
toujours les risques qu'il y avait à ce
moment-là donc tout ça pour vous dire
que ce sont aussi des raisons de
entre guillemets de ce déficit à la fois
de dos mais aussi de perte financière
l'autre chose que je voudrais vous dire
il y a des protocoles pour la prise en
charge du drépanocytaire et c'est vrai
vous l'avez vous avez plus ou moins
répondu à cette question là mais je vous
dis que offert uniquement des
transfusions avec du sang par exemple
qui vient de l'Hexagone de croiser mais
ça peut être aussi de personnes
originaux parce que nous sommes quand
même des douleurs aussi ici ça passe un
problème à terme parce qu'il y a des
réactions auto-immunes il faut le
prendre en compte il y a à terme parce
que vous avez dit les les
drépanocytaires reçoivent autour de 300
vous avez dit pendant leur vie et j'en
connais qui ont déjà 40 ans et plus donc
c'est quand même une bonne chose parce
que c'est autocollant fonctionne très
bien seulement on ne peut pas guérir en
tout cas permettant de vivre mais en
tout cas développer d'autres choses
notamment ces maladies entre immunes et
je souhaiterais vraiment qu'il y ait
pour la Guyane une évaluation de la
situation contenue
il y a également difficile de couverture
médicale c'est vrai que partout en
France on parle de désert médicaux mais
quand certains dans certains lieux on se
passe le médecin et que bien non
médecins des noms médecins
que des personnes qui ne sont pas
médecin habilités peut-être par certains
de vous je ne sais pas s'il y a des
protocoles pour ça mais c'est dangereux
parce qu'il faut de plus en plus dans
les poteaux protocoles et les procédures
après la collecte après le don la
personne doit rester 20 minutes 20
minutes pour qu'on soit sûr qu'elle est
en capacité de repartir dans toute
sécurité et bien là ça va poser un
problème il y a un déficit de de médecin
on a les problèmes des phénotypes c'est
grand seigle et qu'elle qui est négatif
chez les noirs et chez caucasien en tout
cas c'est positif donc ça crée aussi des
problèmes donc il faut vraiment je crois
que je ne peux pas mettre en cause votre
activité
non vous êtes là pour demander qu'on
puisse et vous pourrez mais je crois que
ce sont aussi des choses pour lesquelles
il faudrait contenir des missions qui
sont les vols que vous puissiez les
prendre en compte et les véhicules de
sécurité je ne savais pas plus longue
mais je profite parce que là je suis la
seule ultra-marine prison d'après ce que
je constate oui non non c'est un vrai
sujet mais les véhicules de collecte
parce que les capacités d'aller sur
partout sur le territoire c'est aussi un
frein c'est aussi un vrai parce qu'il y
a des petits bonheurs qui sont peut-être
des douleurs potentiel qui voudraient et
qu'on vienne vers eux parce que la
politique d'aller vers il y a des
personnes qui ont pas de voiture il y a
des problèmes de transport donc là
j'attire votre attention pour vous
donner en tout cas des pistes des pistes
pour améliorer parce que vous nous avez
fait part de difficultés que vous avez
mais moi j'ai des réponses à vous
apporter en dépit de tout ce que vous
avez déjà
dit mais je crois que c'est important
pour que ce service qui est un service
important pour la santé et bien que ce
service puisse continuer et la toute
dernière chose
lors de vos recrutement alors là c'est
une suggestion
vérifiez les numéros Adélie les numéros
Adélie ça existe c'est pas pour rien
parce que vous avez des recrutements qui
ne sont pas forcément conformes et vous
en savez sans doute quelque chose donc
je vais pas aller plus loin merci
beaucoup merci victoire jasmin alors
merci donc
répondre sur les enjeux autour de la
revalorisation juste te dire quand même
que pendant entre 2015 et 2021 nous
n'avons pas eu de revalorisation nous en
avons eu une heure 2021 et c'est tout on
a un vrai sujet dans l'établissement qui
est le sujet du modèle économique on est
aujourd'hui aussi un agent économique si
cet agent économique ne peut pas avoir
un accroissement de ces de ces
ressources même si attention c'est c'est
vrai que c'est l'agent public c'est un
sujet alors combien je les diss entre le
dire tout en le disant si on est à si on
dit qu'on est à zéro et que il y a 30 de
besoins sur des Reval je parle de
millions d'euros désolé 30 sur un choc
de de chiffre d'affaires et 30 de choc
inflationnistes on est à 90 et donc
voilà voilà pour les alors pour répondre
à Madame jasmin moi j'ai quand même vous
me posez des questions mais moi j'ai
aussi des réponses à vous donner
alors première réponse concernant
l'incendie vous en savez plus que moi
mais en tout cas en ce moment il y a une
enquête administrative qui est menée et
cette enquête administrative s'il y a
des choses qu'il faut réparer ou
sanctionner en le fera parce que la
sécurité des personnels sur le
territoire de la République auprès de la
même partout c'est d'ailleurs aussi le
cas madame la sénatrice pour la qualité
des produits sanguins je voudrais quand
même rappeler et j'ai et c'est très
important pour moi
que quand on parle des enjeux d'égalité
par rapport à l'accès à la santé
ce que garantit l'Établissement français
du sang c'est que la poche de sang qui
est donnée à Saint-Laurent du Maroni
qui est donné
à Bordeaux
ou qui est donné à Mayotte c'est
exactement la même qualité
et ça c'est quand même très important
deuxième élément de réponse que je dois
vous donner c'est que on a fait une
étude notamment sur la prise en charge
des drépanocytaires et sur les enjeux
d'aloeilisation notamment
dalo-immunisation on a comparé
l'alo-immunisation à Paris et en Guyane
c'est exactement le même niveau
d'aloeilisation ça ça signifie quoi ça
signifie que effectivement sur des
sujets drépanocytaire nous regardons le
phénotype étendu de la personne afin que
nous puissions donner à la personne le
sang dont elle a besoin sans que ça crée
de problème particulier et ça ça comme
conséquence et vous le savez bien qu'il
faut absolument qu'il y ait plus de
population noire qui vient de donner
leur sang
c'est la raison pour laquelle malgré les
difficultés très fortes que nous avons
de mobilisation notamment notamment en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique que nous que
nous devons continuer à faire des
efforts sur le don du sang je voudrais
aussi rappeler que l'établissement
français du sang
c'est la solidarité nationale
ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est quoi on
essaie de faire en sorte que chacune des
régions soit autosuffisantes toutes les
régions françaises sont aussi
suffisantes sauf
Île-de-France
PACA
Martinique
et Guadeloupe Guyane
c'est sa signification
pour
lesquelles nous encourageons
l'autosuffisance
il est encore des efforts à faire et
donc c'est la solidarité nationale donc
le fait que en CPD à elle en
nouvelle-aquitaine dans le Nord on
collecte plus que le besoin qui permet
de prendre en charge et c'est bien
normal ça s'appelle la solidarité
nationale nos collègues nos compatriotes
Antillais Guyanais
dernière question sur laquelle je vous
le donnais vous donner une réponse
nous collectons partout et le président
de FS son rôle c'est de dire il faut
collecter le plus possible partout
donc nous collectons dans tous les
départements sauf deux
la Guyane et Mayotte pourquoi nous nous
collectons pas en Guyane et pourquoi nos
collègues n'ont pas en maille à Mayotte
question très importante quand même le
directeur général de la Santé le
professeur Salomon signe une lettre en
c'est le directeur général de la santé
si une lettre en 2000 début 2021 pour
demander à santé publique France
d'analyser les conditions d'un retour au
don ou d'un accès aux dons de
l'ouverture aux dons à Mayotte et à et
en Guyane les résultats sont que
épidémiologiquement nous ne pouvons pas
le faire parce que si nous faut le
faisions ça mettrait en cause la santé
des personnes des personnes qui vont
recevoir ces produits pourquoi parce que
tu as ludisme etc etc etc moi je le
redis je crois qu'il y a enfin je et
peut-être que quand je dis ça je suis un
tout petit peu enfin non j'ai dire une
bêtise peut-être que je suis un peu un
feuille de jeu mais je voudrais vraiment
vous dire dire à la représentation
nationale
que
je ne sais pas s'il y a un droit donné
son sang je pense qu'il y a un devoir de
le donner c'est un enjeu de solidarité
mais et donc c'est donc c'est bien par
exemple qu'on ait pu ouvrir le don du
sang aux HSH mais le droit il est quand
même
le droit il est quand même du côté des
patients à recevoir les produits les
plus sécurisés possible
ça veut donc dire que les conditions de
la collecte les populations qui vont
collecter il va falloir qu'on fasse en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas des situations
épidémiologiques telles que ça remette
en cause le fait que la jeune femme qui
va le recevoir pendant qu'elle est en
rouge pardon qu'elle est en train
d'accoucher à Saint-Laurent ou dans
n'importe quel hôpitaux et qui fait une
hémorragie à délivrance puisse avoir un
produit correct qui va lui sauver la vie
et donc ça c'est ça c'est donc un vrai
enjeu un vrai enjeu pour nous je salue
le travail qui est fait par
l'association de
Morne à l'Eau voilà et puis et puis
juste vous dire que c'est Martin c'est
Martely est-ce que Saint-Martin et
Saint-Barthélémy on l'a fait ça coûtait
très cher
ça coûtait très cher donc on l'a fait ça
a été un bon moment un bon moment le
sujet qu'on a aux Antilles c'est un
sujet de recrutement personnel on a
aujourd'hui aux Antilles sur les sur les
et les biologistes et les médecins de
collecte devraient sujets mais moi si
demain on a les personnels on y va
et je le redis madame Pisco vous dites
que vous êtes la seule ultramarie
ici et maintenant comme vous êtes la
seule représentante ultramarine je vous
dis que de mon point de vue la prise en
charge de la collecte dans les DOM et
pour moi quelque chose d'important
première élément la deuxième chose que
je vais vous dire et je partage ça avec
vous c'est que nous devons avoir une
collecte d'autant plus efficace qu'elle
peut aussi soigner certains de nos
compatriotes antillais qui vivent en
Île-de-France par exemple
mais si vous voulez avoir plus de
donneurs sur nos territoires je vous ai
donné quand même quelques pistes parce
que quand on a des camions qui ne
fonctionnent pas correctement et qu'on
est obligé de rester les autour de ce
soir
tout le monde ne peut pas venir à l'EFS
alors qu'on a quand même ne serait-ce
qu'en Guadeloupe les îles de Guadeloupe
on peut faire et partout alors moi je
pense qu'il faut aussi que vous mettiez
de votre côté les moyens qui nécessaires
pour avoir plus de donneurs je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour cet échange dont on me dit que non
dans ton me dit qu'il a été non pas un
peu long parce que c'est un réel sujet
et qui a été largement évoqué dans le
PLFSS que dont on entend beaucoup parler
sur nos territoires notamment avec les
associations d'honneur et moi pour avoir
participé il y a quelques semaines à une
campagne de
démarchage si je puis dire dans dans la
de recrutement dans la ville d'Angers un
après-midi pour l'opération mon sang
pour les autres
j'ai vu qu'il y avait beaucoup beaucoup
de jeunes en effet qui souhaitaient
donner et même certains qui étaient pas
dans les âges qui disaient on attend
d'avoir l'âge pour pouvoir donner une
vraie une vraie réponse très très forte
de beaucoup de personnes des plus âgés
regrettantes d'être vieux et des jeunes
regrettant d'être jamais beaucoup de
jeunes qui donnaient donc je pense qu'on
est fait merci de votre attention et
soyez assuré de ma mobilisation voilà
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame